is curiosity a more powerful force in
the universe than
violence and
the will to power
so uh because you said you frame
curiosity as a way to also plan on how
to avoid violence which is an
interesting framing of curiosity but i i
could also argue that
violence is a pretty productive way
to uh operate in the world
which is like that's one way to protect
yourself the best defense is offense
um i'm not qualified to answer this but
i'll have a go i think violent let's not
talk about violence that's the summary
of this podcast
i would yeah maybe i would let's call it
violence but i call it erasure so if you
think about um the way evolution works
all the way uh
um obviously cool right assembly's
theory but
so if you say you you you build pro
curiosity allows you to open up avenues
new graphs right so
new features you can play
what
what the ability to erase those things
allows you to start again and do some
pruning so the universe i think
curiosity gets you further curiosity
gets you rockets that land it gets you
robots that can make drugs it gets you
poetry and art and communication and
then you know i often think wouldn't it
be great in bureaucracy to have another
world war not literally a world war now
please no world war but a the equivalent
so we could get remove all the admin
bureaucracy right all the admin violence
get rid of it and start again do you
know what i mean because you get layers
and you get redundant systems built so
actually
a reset let's call it violence a reset
in some aspects of our
um
culture and our our technology allows us
to then
build more important things without the
because how many you know how many
cookies do i have to click on how many
think how many
how many extra clicks i do i have in the
future of my life that i could remove
and a bit of
a reset would would allow us to
to uh to start again and maybe that's
how i suppose our encounter with aliens
will be maybe they will fight with us
and say uh he went on as excited by you
so we thought we'll just get rid of you
so they might want to reset earth yeah
why not to be like let's see how the
evolution runs again this seems like uh
they've uh
uh there's nothing new happening here
they're observing for a while this is
just not let's keep it more fun let's
start with the fish again
i like how you equated violence to um
resetting your cookies
i suppose that's the kind of violence in
this this modern world where wards or
violence resetting cookies i don't know
where that came from i'm complete yeah
it's poetic uh really
you